the view is a bit more complicated than
the model in this application it's an
object as you can see by this open
bracket right here and it has two
methods in it and render we call a knit
to skip things set up and we call render
to update our view now the HTML is also
part of the view so I've opened up index
dot HTML you can see we have a button
here and an unordered list for all of
our pizzas there's also this script
template down here which is just a fancy
word for some HTML that we're going to
use again and again when we make the
pizza objects let's hop back into our
app j/s first let's go over our init
function here now for the moment I'll
ask you not to get too mired in the
details we're really looking at the
overarching organization of the
application okay so simplified and
glossing over details we're doing the
following first we're adding an event
listener for the button which runs the
ad pizza function then we're grabbing
some things from the DOM and we're
storing them to variables so that way we
can use them in our next step then we're
adding a click listener for the pizza
list and if we're clicking on a remove
pizza button we're running the function
that figures out what we've clicked on
and then ultimately calls the remove
pizza function and lastly we're telling
the view to render itself so speaking of
rendering itself what does that render
function actually do in a nutshell it
clears the pizza list entirely and re
renders all the visible pizzas not very
smart or optimized but it works just
fine so clearing the Pizza list and here
getting the visible pizzas from our
octopus which we'll talk about later and
for each one of those pizzas doing the
following filling in the template HTML
with the pizza ID and then adding it to
the pizza list in the Dom so this view
here is not particularly smart but it is
separated out and that's what's most
important all of our view logic is in
one place rather than scattered
throughout our entire application we'll
see the ramifications of this in the
next note